rioting broke out in minneapolis again
over the weekend it happened so often
now especially in minneapolis that you
don't even
notice anymore of course part of the
reason you don't notice it is that the
media doesn't really cover it
and they don't cover it because for
obvious political and ideological
reasons but i also think
that it's it's hardly even news anymore
because it happens so often not to give
the media an excuse for not reporting
because they should
but at the same time i think everyone
almost has the same attitude
of uh oh yeah blm is riding again what
else is new
oh they burned down three buildings they
do do it all the time at a certain point
it just becomes part of the
the background um and it shouldn't be
but that's what it becomes because
they're allowed to do this over and over
again
for months and years on end but
that's what was happening and this time
the martyr of choice is a guy named
winston bougie smith as far as i know
bougie is
his real middle name it's not a nickname
i could be wrong about that but
this is from fox9 let me read a little
bit of the report to you
it says winston bougie smith as
identified by family and friends was
shot by a ramsey
county deputy and a hennepin county
deputy during an encounter on the top
floor of the parking garage in the 1400
block
of lake street thursday afternoon
a u.s marshals fugitive task force was
attempting to arrest smith 32 years old
for a walk for a warrant on a felony
firearms violation when the incident
occurred
um bca investigators that's the bureau
of criminal apprehension
say there's evidence showing that smith
fired his gun from inside the vehicle
and spent casings were found on the
driver's side however there's no body
camera footage or squad dash cam footage
of the incident
the bca says members of the task force
weren't allowed to wear body cameras
despite a change in policy at the
federal level
allowing for the use of cameras by
officers and deputies on the task force
at the same time
social media postings seem to show smith
was prepared for a confrontation with
police an internal document from law
enforcement quote smith as saying quote
that he would quote shoot it out if he
was ever pulled off
um by law enforcement okay so
i mean that's really all you need to
know that
he he was a wanted felon
fugitive from justice that they were
pursuing
he had a gun this was not an unarmed
suit in no way was this an unarmed
man getting shot by cops he had a gun he
had an illegal gun because he's a felon
and a fugitive and you're not allowed to
have guns when you're a felon in a
fugitive
um and he shot he used it he was
shooting
at the police the the spent shell
casings in the car
pretty well confirms that
so a wanted fugitive violent felon
armed resisting arrest
and putting all that aside you know even
even all of that doesn't matter
like the only thing that really matters
here is that he was shooting at the
police
and he got shot
literally any if you shoot at the cops i
don't care who you are
it doesn't matter if you're not a felon
you could be the greatest guy in the
world you could be mr rogers
um shooting at the cops and you're gonna
get shot
perfectly fair in fact we could go even
further than that
like you shoot at anyone who has a gun
and you're gonna get shot
legally
uh but so that's all you really need to
know about this
and that on top of the fact that he had
previously announced his intention to
shoot it out with the cops and then he
did shoot it out with the cops
but we could we could add some more
information he also had i think it was
20 arrests
under his belt um
including and he he had previously
online had encouraged
not only had he announced his intention
to shoot it out with the cops an
intention which he then followed through
on
but he had encouraged the burning of
police stations he was encouraging
violence against police officers
and then he went and committed that
violence himself but one of his arrests
and i almost don't need to tell you this
because you know this is coming
i'll let you fill in the blanks because
there's one thing we know about blm
martyrs
almost in almost every almost every time
they are violent felons
in the process of resisting arrest and
assaulting or trying to kill cops
and what's what's one crime
one type of crime that they almost
always have committed
in the past violence against women
right so many cases of that whether it's
george floyd
jacob blake etc um and that was the case
here too
winston bougie smith had 20 arrests
aggravated robbery of a woman
being one of them and i believe the
woman was his like his ex-girlfriend or
something
he committed aggravated robbery against
her
it it really is it's almost it's an
impressive track record
with blm every single
martyr that they choose ends up being
not only a violent felon but someone
specifically who had committed violence
against women
this is so common it's like they're
they're sifting through all of the
potential
martyrs that they can choose and it's
almost like they intentionally choose
the ones
who have committed some kind of violent
act against a woman
either it's an intentional choice or
it's a hell of a coincidence
that at this point you you you can
assume it
when blm is rioting over someone being
shot by the cops you could
before you even know the person's name
you can just assume that they've
committed some violent act against a
woman in the past because that's it's
always the case
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated